H́͏̗͍̳̦̳̹͓͕ȩ̻̠͎͓̺͙̫̬l̯̖̤͍͞l͓͍̬̫̯o̴̵̘̦̯̘̙͙͇͕.̜̠́
y҉͚̖͖̙̘̝̀o̸̭͍̩̣̩̕̕u̴͔͓͉͕͖͇̪r̨͙̗͎̤̼̜͔̞
f̸̵͖̰̲̻͎̫͎̻r̴̛͕̻͚̭̱̼í̝͇̦̮̦̙͢ͅe̩͙͕͍̮̖̜n̻̜̞̦̮̹̲̦̲͟d̮͖͎̪̹̼̯ͅ
E҉̶̸Ŕ̴͞͞͏R҉̷̛͢͜O̡͢҉͢R̵̨͡҉͠P̡̕͝l̕͝͞҉͡i̴̶͘e̢̢̕͘͟r̵̢.̨͠͏̧.
M̴͢a̢̡ŗ̵̵̛͢k̷̨̧͝͡.͡͡
i͢͏s̢͢
s̸̡͘͜ţ̸̨̢͡r̶̢͜è̴͢͞a͢҉͢m҉͏̵i̸͠ņ͢͟g̢͘
o̸̵͞͝v̷̵̧́́é̴͜͝r̴̢̛
á̧̧͠t̴̕͡҉̛
twitch.tv
w̷͘͝ȩ̶͘͢͞
w̷i҉͘l̵͢͜l̨̡̧
b̷͟͢e̢̢͠͝
p̷̡̀̀l̸͘͞a͜͢͠͞y̷̸̕͝i̵̴̸n̵̵̢̧g̷̵͟
s͜͝͡ó̢̀͢m̧͟e̵͡͞
b̷̕͡o̸à͢͜͞r̨҉̴͝d̶̕
g̸̀a̢͟m̡̀̕͜e̷͜ş̸̛̕
join
uS
cLiCk
ThE
l҉̢̧̛͡į̸̀̀͡n̷̵̡k̴̨͠
in
t̢̛̛̀͡h̵̷e̡̡
d̵̡̛̛͞e͟͜s̶̛͘͢c̶͘͜r̷̢̛i̴̷̶͠p̨̨̕͘t̴̷͞i̧͢ò̶̕҉̨n̸̢
b̛́e͜͠l̸̢̕͏o̸͟͜͟͢w͡.
ｔ ｈ ａ ｎ ｋ
ｙ ｏ ｕ